- So I think the takeaway
is that I need to date guys
who literally have no idea
who Chase is.
- I think the takeaway
is "no more fish oil."
- Yeah, we are off of that.
Oh, hey, did you get
all the followers you needed?
- No!
I even tried making
an ASMR video.
- One of those whisper videos?
Ain't right, ain't natural.
- Yeah, I actually
lost followers on that video,
so now I need 10,073
by tomorrow.
- Wait.
Who's this skank?
[phone vibrating]
- Oh, my God, it's Colby.
"Wanna come hike
with us, bitch?
We got an extra animal onesie."
- Eww.
- Hiking in onesies?
Do you know how many photos
they're gonna take?
Okay, I gotta go.
I think I should do something
to my hair,
'cause their hair
is always so cool.
I'm just gonna--
- Are you becoming
an Instagay?
- What? No. No.
I just want to book
this miniseries.
Okay, bye.
Good luck on all
your dates today.
- Bye.
[upbeat music]
So you've never
heard of ChaseDreams
or his music?
- Nah.
I don't know who that is.
- Perfect.
- Only music I listen to
is Phish.
Seen 'em live 712 times.
♪ ♪
- And then, like,
the whole Uber
reeked of taco salad.
I'm like, "I have to give
this guy five stars.
I feel so bad."
[all laughing]
- Great story, five stars.
But, guys, uh, right here
is very picturesque.
Could we take
a picture here, maybe?
- Cary, you're seriously
cracking me up.
[laughter]
- No, I haven't heard
of ChaseDreams or Phish.
I--I don't like music.
- Hot.
What do you like?
- Books.
Books, I love.
I love reading books,
talking about books.
- But then I was like,
instead of just telling her
the truth, I'll just
let her have it.
Like, it doesn't hurt me.
You know what I mean?
- Hey, guys, what about this?
What about this?
What a funny image, right?
Imagine scrolling past this.
Me as a hot cow.
- Oh, my God, a baby bird!
[all gasp, exclaim]
- Out here?
- Oh, my God!
all: Aww!
- So nice to meet you.
Congrats again on getting
rescued from that basement!
- You okay?
Can I get you anything?
- Yeah, you can knock me out
and wake me when I'm dead.
- Horse troubles?
- What?
No, didn't you just see
all those awful dates
I was on?
- Yeah.
Not a winner in the bunch.
- No.
I--I just started dating
because I was so consumed
with work, and then it just
ended up being more work.
- You know what my sister did?
- I don't.
- My sister was so fed up
with the dating scene
that she posted an ad
saying that she would be
wearing a red dress
standing in Madison Square Park
holding a single red rose,
and she invited
any handsome bachelor
to come by,
sweep her off her feet.
She's now been married
eight years.
- [scoffs]
Nuh-uh.
That is so dumb.
I would never do that
in a million--
- Oh, my God, yes.
- Okay.
Beautiful, right?
- Yep, so let's take
a picture.
- Huh?
- I said
let's take a picture
right here with this
beautiful...lake.
- Oh, we're just here
for the nature.
It's No-Post Sunday.
- "No-Post Sunday"?
Then why the hell
am I hanging out with you?
- Excuse me?
- Cameron, what's happening?
Cary's not being funny.
- ♪ If ever ♪
♪ Love was real ♪
- Are you...Brooke?
- Wow.
♪ ♪
You're gorgeous.
- So are you.
- I can't believe it.
I mean,
you knew nothing about me,
and you saw an ad
on Craigslist and--
and decided to take a chance
on a stranger
in Madison Square Park.
That's...
pathetic.
You're a loser.
I'm a loser.
I'm sorry.
I have to leave.
- I'm a loser?
- If we're not taking pictures,
what's with
these stupid onesies?
- They're comfy.
Not everything we do
is to get a picture.
- Cary, were you
just, like, using us
to leech off our followers?
- Cary, we thought you liked us
for who we are,
not our work.
- You call what you do "work"?
All you do is get naked
and post pictures
and have sex with each other!
- We don't have sex
with each other.
- What?
Why don't you?
both: We're virgins.
- And I'm straight.
- And I used to be fat
but now I have two nieces.
- That's not a thing, Drake.
Okay, that's the problem
with you guys.
You don't do anything!
I actually do something.
I act.
- Like what?
What are you in?
- I'm trying to do something,
but the way this business works
is you gotta do stupid shit
like this to even get
to that level.
So I'm gonna go over here,
and I'm gonna pose
like a little pouty cow,
and you're gonna take a picture
and [BLEEP] tag me!
Wait, are you filming?
Please don't film.
- "Do not trust
this thirsty..."
- Don't.
- "Shady bitch..."
- Cameron, no.
- "@CaryDubek."
- No, please don't post that.
Please don't.
- Sad.
- Please don't.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I just got
100 new followers.
Could you actually tweet that?